we get our first look at tony santian a
kid coming up from aaa to start this
series tonight yeah 0-1 on the year and
two starts with a 4-7 era you see there
made his debut on june the 13th was 1-3
with a 2-5 era
six games in louisville this year so
he's throwing the ball well down there
well he definitely is that and
check swing try clearly too far strike
three nice breaking ball right there the
batter's freddie freeman leads the
braves in all those categories and just
hit another one oh yeah
that one's headed for the bleachers a
long home run for freddy freeman on the
first pitch
one nothing atlanta freeman's 17th homer
prone and likely that you'll find in
baseball
off speed swinging to miss santiago a
couple of k's on his secondary stuff
[Applause]
wallops that pitch to deep center
naquin
at the wall
makes the catch right in front of the
reds bullpen
another smash by the braves
the rookie tony santion gets a couple
the case reds grab their bats
and as we said jesse chavez surprisingly
will start a bullpen game for the braves
tonight yeah jesse's been around a long
time so you know he's going to be out
there not be intimidated by the
situation you see 13 games in gwinnett
1-0 record with a 2-2-5-e-r-a
india's swing smashes that ball to right
misplayed by abdullah it's into the
right-field corner
india steaming towards second base just
now gathered fired in he'll slow it
second with a stand up double
castianos climbs in with his average
resting at 3 40. 13 homers he's knocked
in 38.
well hit to right
call to the fly tag at second and third
throw into the plate freeman snaps it
off to third no chance for a tag
candia scores winker claims third base
one out sac fly rbi to tie the game
got the top of the zone that time and
chavez strikes out vato and naquin
looking and strands
jesse winker 90 feet away
that one whacked into right field of
base hit and almante will stop at second
the braves have the first two on with
nobody out
good at bat by eddie
weak wave and a miss
speed away three k's first time through
the nine for the rookie tony santiago
[Applause]
and now he's back
at the great american ball park
and he gets hey juenio suarez to swing
and miss suarez a lot of power but boy a
lot of strikeouts that's 87 of them
mustaches has been hurt
as this ball is cracked toward right
field pretty well hit but playable for
adrianza he's got it and now the reds
have the defensive line if they want
they're just waiting for the moose to
come back and a good start for jesse
chavez top of the order coming up in a
1-1 game
so dan's be back to work one-two pitch
lift it high again this one
might be playable barnhart to the
warning track he's going to have room
right in front of the first base camera
payoff
swing in the miss he struck him out
the rookie santiago
four k's today two against the
three-hole hitter in olbis
and the miners hit 222 with a double
jesse chavez bashed in the left the
first big league hit for santiago it's a
big turn
a stand-up doubled by the big fella
congratulations to the rook
in his third career start
they're going to intentionally walk nick
castiano's
to get the left on left match-up against
joey bottom payoff runner from first go
sharp liner to short in between on the
backhand swats and throwing a first not
in time bottle legs it out santiago
scores reds lead to one winker comes in
a few steps in left down and in swinging
on this strike three
consecutive case for
and a career-high six through four
but santana's way ahead one ball two
strikes
and he came back to get him how about
that performance fly out strikeout
strikeout and the reds waist two on
nobody out edgar looking good we're
through four two one cincinnati
swing of the miss
career-high seven strikeouts three in a
row
swinging to miss strike three
but he had the most runs created against
fastballs in all of baseball that's what
he killed
santiago the perfect ending eight
strikeouts for the rookie
and they'll get the meds here starting
tuesday
and how about that from sean newcomb
that's what we want to see yeah
hopefully that'll continue terrific
inning for newcomb three up three down
and we head to the sixth
runner's dance draws the eye 1-2
grounded
farm bird shorts snap shovel close play
out of force
they nip out to the anza at second base
and tony santiago
walks off to a raucous elevation see if
we take a shot with the breaking ball
stevenson a local kid from kennesaw and
he grounds to third reilly gets him and
sean nukem with two very effective
innings keeps it a 2-1 game
dansby swanson
first pitch popped up
farmer out nate went in naked makes the
catch as farmer stumbles and that's a
one two three inning
so ag does the job so india moves up in
the scoring position for nick
castellanos 2-2
driven high in the air deep left center
field oh this one could go to orbit
nick castellanos destroys a two-run
homer
and the reds lengthen their lead it's
four to one in the home seven
and ozzy albies will be the batter
ozzy jumps on the first one and hits a
line drive homer you're never out of a
game in cincinnati late atlanta's got
him first and third adrianza is up
line drive right field of base head a
run is in it's a four to three game the
braves are almost back from the brink
the lead in peril two outs two strikes
his pitch
chipped in the air caught on the fly
kyle farmer
ends the inning as they leave them
loaded
let's see how martin and company trying
to attack castellanos
first pitch belted deep right center
off the wall india rounds third stop
sign for winker castello slows winker
level it along now he's in a rundown
so castillanos gets his fourth rbi the
reds solve their lead
santion gave the reds six strong innings
and stands in line for his first big
league win
swinging a miss
brad brock slams the door shut as he
bolts down the save and the reds win it
5-3 over the braves